hey 42 here existence is strange and
there's no way we can ever manage to
understand all the many mysteries of
life the universe and everything when we
come across something we don't
understand most of us turn to teachers
parents smart friends or probably
Wikipedia in an attempt to sort out what
what some people don't like to close
their eyes stick out their finger and
believe whatever crazy solution it lands
on and this isn't just reserved for the
darkest corners of the internet many
public figures and celebrities have
dived headfirst into the pool of
pseudoscience conspiracies and good
old-fashioned nonsense today we look at
famous people without rageous theories
of beliefs gravity seems to be a problem
in a number of wild theories but one of
the best surely has to come from
internet personality David avocado Wolfe
he's the least famous person on this
list but he deserves first billing
because of the sheer ludicrous E of his
beliefs you probably all have a friend
who share his steady stream of vague and
generally harmless motivational memes he
has almost 6 million followers on
Facebook and built a career as a raw
food enthusiast promoting a variety of
super foods and supplements oh and he
believes that gravity doesn't exist as
we know it and it is actually a toxin
that we should get rid of there are many
videos of him both interviews and
recordings of public lectures where he
puts forward a range of theories about
various foods on the body but his
gravitationally questionable theory is
that he believes salt is basically the
gatekeeper of water and to quote him the
reasons why the oceans are salty is
that's what's needed to hold the water
onto the earth if that didn't happen the
water would levitate right off the earth
and that would be the end of it he
doesn't say what happens to the unsalted
fresh water rivers and lakes but let's
just assume they're tied down with some
magic rope or maybe the fish to scrape
onto it really really tight
he loves solve for its ability to keep
water retained in your muscles
he even recommends just having it lying
around your house to prevent allergies
insomnia and migraines have you ever
seen a peanut with a migraine
no exactly but the wolf's expertise do
not end there
here is a brief outline of some of his
other wonderful fears chocolate lined up
Planet airily with the Sun chocolate is
an octave of sun energy and that
children is why you should always eat up
all your KitKat's
but seriously chocolate lines above the
Sun what does that even mean here's
another omniscient quote of his mushroom
spores can levitate off the planet
because they are surrounded by a shell
of illness which is actually trying to
get to the center of the Sun I didn't
think mushroom takers intended to get
quite that high in case you're curious
allness is an idea created by David
Hudson in 1975 they are supposedly
precious metals without molecular bonds
so all the atoms exist separately and
yes you're right that is complete
nonsense and one more of david wells
series is that deer antler is not a
product it's a cosmic substance I'm not
sure the deer will feel that way as you
chop their space horns off their heads
he believes the horns make you younger
did I forget to mention he's also a
flatterer - along with a load of other
nonsense theories but I think I'll stop
there I need to go and eat some salt
before I float away again another David
now this time X BBC sports presenter
David David Icke started out as a
goalkeeper
unfortunately arthritis forced him to
retire at just 21 but he went on to
carve out a successful career as a
sports presenter eventually co-hosting
the BBC show grandstand the most watched
sports show in the UK due to his
arthritis he began looking into fringe
medicine and New Age philosophies which
led him to become involved with the
Green Party and also to an important
meeting with a psychic who
hold him he had been sent to heal the
world she didn't exactly say what was
wrong with the world
some sort of stomach bug I presume but
nevertheless david icke was the man to
heal it apparently he began developing
an even more elaborate theory about why
the world had gotten to such a state of
war sickness and poverty realizing that
there must be a shadowy cabal behind all
this mischief he believes that
civilization was set up by a group of
alien reptiles called the babylonian
Brevard their bloodline continues to
this day and they control everything
from the United Nations and the media
led by the famous loominatee a
mysterious group of ward leaders feared
by tinfoil hat wearers and internet
keyboard warriors across the world yes
I'm looking at you the reptiles
apparently came from a constellation
called Draco and were drawn to earth not
for the margaritas and well-organized
bus routes but for the monatomic and
gold which is just another name for the
allness that we mentioned earlier that
impossible form of metal where none of
the atoms are bonded together so yeah
you're healing me correctly David Eick
believes the world is run by lizards
with notable figures such as the Queen
and most prime ministers and presidents
being part of this omniscient lizard
species the reptiles are shape-shifting
obviously and can take human form so
you'd better keep your wits about you if
you do catch anyone looking hungrily
after dead insects then it's probably
best to bow down to them in case they
are one of your overseeing lizard Lords
oh one more thing he also believes he is
the son of God I'll just leave that out
there do you believe in life after love
yes I do sure but I'm not quite sure I
believe in life after relying solely on
homeopathic treatments sure is not alone
in her support of homeopathy a whole
host of stars from Pamela Anderson to
tina turner and monica bellucci and many
of us have all come out in favor of it
now alternative medicine is a
complicated field containing many
treatments that may do real good but
have yet to
proven scientifically things like
acupuncture traditional Chinese
medicines and chiropractic for example
there is a lot of anecdotal evidence
about their effectiveness but this has
not been backed up by clinical testing
yet the same cannot be said however
about homeopathy trial after trial has
proven without a doubt that the practice
has no benefits beyond the placebo
effect in one of his most recent tests
Paul glacier from Bond University in
Australia oversaw 176 individual studies
and found absolutely no difference
between homeopathy and the placebo
effect for 68 different illnesses so
hopefully they can stop wasting their
time and now start looking into more
important theories such as if eating
carrots helped you see in the dark
if I eat rabbits will I see an infra red
so what is homeopathy invented by Samuel
Hahnemann in 1796 it follows three laws
the law of similars the law of
infinitesimally and the law of
succussion if the last one sounds like a
made-up word that's because it is the
law of similars means finding a cure
that is similar to the symptoms such as
caffeine for insomnia or onions to treat
the streaming guys from hay fever then
the law of infinitesimally means that
the more you dilute the substance in
water the more it increases its potency
which is just as ludicrous and
contradictory as it sounds the lower
caution just tells you that you should
shake or tap the container during each
mix so that the water maintains a memory
of the substance a lot of medicines in
homeopathy are sold as either 30 c or
100 C whether C stands for scent tesam
or
1c is one drop of the substance added to
99 drops of water to see is one drop
taken from that previous solution which
remember is 1% substance 99% water and
then added to another 99 drops of water
so 30 C is this same process repeated 30
times over making it one part per
million million million million million
numbers this big are kind of meaningless
so let me give you an analogy to dilute
one full drop of substance in a 30 C
solution you would need enough water to
cover every single planet in 500 million
universes so I'll get a bucket you
better start the rate that's basically
when you buy homeopathic treatment you
are literally paying for very expensive
water when asked most homeopathy
consumers thought that what they were
actually taking was pills containing
some kind of herbal extracts but in
reality the original substance which was
diluted in it was lost long long ago
Jonah's repeated dilution process what
you're actually left with is water
infused sugar pills but having said all
this the placebo effect is real it even
works in animals and something with a
long standing history like homeopathy
even if it is based on a scientific
falsehood and we have repeatedly proved
that it does not work is actually still
quite likely to work and be effective on
individuals who believe it to be true
because their placebo effect after the
treatment will be more powerful now if
homeopathy requires you to reject some
of your understandings of science then
grammy-nominated rapper b.o.b would like
you to tear up all your textbooks and
make a new paper mache model of the
world in his single flatline he laid out
his belief that we live on a flat earth
he claims we have all been indoctrinated
in a cult called science and calls out
famous astrophysicist Neil deGrasse
Tyson claiming he has been paid off the
scientist alone
his nephew even created a retaliation
rap - b.o.b so how did b.o.b end up with
his bizarre conclusion that the world is
a spinning plate mankind has actually
known the world is round for a very very
long time since it explains to where
that ships disappear over the horizon
and why during a lunar eclipse it is
possible to see the shadow that earth
makes on the moon and you can quite
clearly see that it's a sphere flat
earthers believe the world is a disc
with the Arctic Circle in the middle and
the Antarctic acting as a wall of ice
surrounding the big plate you can't walk
over the edge because the wall is
guarded by NASA possibly all the skies
of penguins now I'm sure you have some
questions like what about the Sun
what about planes and satellites and if
earth is a plate does that mean we're
all someone for lunch
according to flat surface the Sun and
Moon are apparently spheres measuring 51
kilometers across and they move in
circles above the earth just under five
thousand kilometers away shining down
like spotlights the Sun has a slightly
spiraled orbit to account for its
changing position in the seasons there's
also an anti movement which causes
eclipses and it's made of crackers so
you can eat it together with the cheese
from the actual moon and it's delicious
oh wait that's wallace and gromit
how the Sun stays up there is a
different matter since gravity isn't
real according to their theory the earth
is accelerating upwards at 9.8 meters
per second squared like were on some
sort of interstellar pancake elevator so
when you slip you're not falling the
world is just high-fiving you in the
face
all of NASA's achievements have been
faked of course and every photo of the
earth is just a nifty bit of
photoshopping even before Photoshop was
invented and when it comes to air travel
well all GPS has been ripped so pilots
think they are traveling around the
sphere but in fact are just wasting all
our time taking the scenic route in a
big circle the approach of the believers
is to follow something called the
zetetic method which values sensory
observation above rational thinking so
if the world looks flat it must be flat
right well by this logic
that tree is not far away he's just very
very small and Donald Trump is exactly
what he appears to be an angry
genetically modified potato
Billy Corgan sprang to fame in the 90s
as the face of the band Smashing
Pumpkins he became one of the largest
rock bands of the era their albums
Mellon Collie and the infinite sadness
and Siamese Dream are ranked at 82 and
362 respectively in the Rolling Stone
magazine's list of greatest albums of
all time
but Billy dreamed no longer recently
describing himself and Motley Crue
drummer Tommy Lee as awake this is
conspiracy fearing linger for seeing
what is really going on behind a shadowy
curtain and one of his current theories
of choice is a notorious chemtrails
when you look up into the sky on a
bright cloudless day you'll occasionally
see the white plume left in the wake of
a passing plane Corgan along with other
stars such as beck and kylie jenner
believe that these clouds are chemicals
that the government is intentionally
pumping into the atmosphere why would
they do this well Bob to make people
sick and get money through
pharmaceutical sales maybe it's some
sort of mind control technique weather
modification or perhaps just to use a
sky as a gigantic etch-a-sketch in
reality these trails are caused by a
couple of factors most importantly the
exhaust coming from the engines is
hotter than the surrounding air so the
difference in temperature allows water
to condense and then freeze thanks to
the ambient temperature and the high
altitude the particles in the exhaust
such as sorts and sulfur compounds often
serve as a site for this condensation
and freezing to take place it's also
possible for the change in pressure
caused by the wings in the body of the
plane to act as a trigger for this these
contrails condensation trails can remain
for minutes or even hours depending on
the atmospheric conditions at the time
these trails may have an environmental
impact since they can form sizeable
clouds but their effect is limited to
how they reflect heat radiation rather
than the chemical content of the class
themselves even if chemtrail believers
reject these explanations there's still
one major flaw in their theory since
given the height of the plains any
chemicals being sprayed out would
dissipate over hundreds of miles and
lose their potency long before they
reach the ground below but as for Billy
he still believes that we cannot be
saved
musicians nutritionists and sports
presenters are one thing but what
happens when the world's most powerful
man has a bizarre Theory close to his
heart former US President Ronald Reagan
was an avid believer in numerology
numerology covers a range of
superstitions about the relationship of
numbers with people and events often in
the realm of the paranormal and relating
to divination and astrology some form of
number base belief is common in many
cultures with lucky and unlucky numbers
being created from the sounds and
symbols of the words or perhaps with
their religious connections such as the
holy trinity or the Twelve Apostles in
Christianity and may the 4th in Judaism
for Reagan led largely by his wife Nancy
and her favorite astrologer Joan Quigley
this mostly manifested itself in how he
scheduled certain events he delayed his
inauguration as governor of California
by 9 minutes to put it at the most
opportune moment he even used numerology
to decide the set up of the Reykjavik
summit in 1986 where Reagan and
Gorbachev laid the groundwork for the
end of the Cold War I would not have
liked to be in the translator who had to
tell Gorbachev we're just waiting until
Mars enters Uranus maybe his many
psychics did actually help him though as
he was finally able to overcome the
curse of tippecanoe ninth president
William Harrison was involved in a war
with a Native American tribe called the
Shawnee including the Battle of
Tippecanoe supposedly a Shawnee prophet
called Tenskwatawa
cursed Harrison and since then every
president elected on a 20th year
anniversary are William Harrison has
died in
this this includes Lincoln Garfield
McKinley as well as Harding's heart
attack and Roosevelt cerebral
hemorrhaging and JFK but after Reagan
became president the curse seemed to
have been broken
thanks to Reagan's belief in magic
numbers George W Bush elected in 2000
was able to survive three attempted
assassinations and attacked by a
journalist shoe choking on a pretzel and
as one of the lucky members of the White
House not to be shot in the face by Dick
Cheney whilst hunting it's somehow
reassuring to know that no matter how
famous or powerful you become you can
still be scared of monsters under the
bed and believe in magical curses and
treatments that could fix us all in an
instant
I personally sometimes have this creepy
feeling that I'm being watched by
mysterious strangers from all around the
world silly isn't it thanks for the view
subscribe for more thoughty2 meet the
most audacious granddad's this side of a
Sunday roast the so called
grandpa gang pulled off the largest
burglary in English history welcome to
the weirdest city in Alaska Whittier
what Whittier is the city that forgot
how to city because it is home to just
220 people and they all live in one
building